[Musique]
jonas vie un chagrin d'amour qu'il
décide d'aller noyer dans la ville où il
a grandi à la fermeture
il n'est plus dans son état normal il
est conscient que son taux d'alcoolémie
est bien au dessus de la limite permise
pour conduire alors il s'étend sur la
banquette arrière pour dégriser
mais il est réveillé par un policier qui
lui demande de passer un test
d'alcoolémie
jonas les choux lamentablement
le policier lui remet une contravention
de 1000 $ et il lui annonce que son
permis est suspendu pour trois mois
je n'en sais rien ou le coeur il était
certain d'avoir pris une bonne décision
en ne prenant pas le volant mais selon
le code criminel et le code de la
sécurité routière
si vous vous trouvez dans votre véhicule
et que mots-clés sont accessibles on
considère que vous pourriez démarrez
votre voiture à tout moment les
sanctions sont les mêmes que si vous
aviez conduit avec des facultés
affaiblies
le fin mot de l'histoire ne fait pas en
sorte que leurs peines de coeur surtout
en peine de prison